-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys,
it's Halloween weekend.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And get this --
here in New York City,
it's gonna be 80 degrees.
[ Laughter ]
80 degrees.
But everyone's mom
will still make them wear
a jacket over their costume.
[ Laughter ]
"I don't want you to be chilly.
Everyone knows you're
Spider-Man."
[ Laughter ]
You know it's too hot
when you see houses
covered in fried eggs.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You know it's too hot
when you bob for apples
and just kind of stay there.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some news.
I saw that President Biden's
approval rating
among his fellow Democrats
just dropped 11 points
to a record low of 75%.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Yikes.
Even Jill is like,
"So tell me more about
this Robert Kennedy fella."
[ Laughter ]
If Biden becomes
any less popular,
Republicans might elect him
speaker of the House.
-Oh!
[ Audience groans ]
-That's correct.
Yeah, Biden's down to 75%.
On the bright side,
he gets to tell people
that he's in his mid 70s again.
-Aww.
[ Laughter ]
When Biden asks how
he could boost his numbers,
his staff said, "Try walking
from the car to the plane
without making people think,
"Oh, God, oh, God,
oh, God, oh God!"
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "Is he walking --
Is he walking on skates?
Is he wearing ice skates
in the parking lot?"
Don't worry. Biden has a way
to boost his popularity. Yeah.
He's gonna become
pickleball partners
with the Golden Bachelor.
[ Laughter ]
No, actually,
this is gonna help him.
He's now rebranding himself
as Joe Biden: Taylor's Version.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's how you do it.
Smart.
[ Cheering continues ]
Some --
Some movie news.
Today, the new horror movie
"Five Nights at Freddy's"
hit theaters and started
streaming on Peacock.
Yeah, it is being called
the "Casablanca" of movies
featuring giant robot animals
in a pizzeria.
[ Laughter ]
It is a horror movie that is set
in a place like Chuck E. Cheese.
Yeah. It's terrifying.
In one scene, they shine
a black light on the ball pit.
-Oh!
-Eee.
Hey, did you guys see this?
The magician David Copperfield
just announced plans
to make the Moon disappear.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's an amazing trick
he calls daytime.
[ Laughter ]
Un...
Yep. David Copperfield will
make the Moon disappear.
Yeah.
Then for his next trick,
he threatened to pull
a rabbit out of Uranus.
-And that's --
-Hey-o!
-What? What?
[ Rimshot ]
-What?!
-Guys, I read that
since people started
going back to work,
the makers of Axe deodorant
have seen a 15% surge in sales.
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
-Of course, Axe body spray
is very popular
because it can also
be used as mace.
[ Laughter ]
Some more business news.
For the first time in 50 years,
Cup Noodles is making a change
to their cups
by switching from styrofoam
to paper.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not to be alarmed, though, the
noodles will still be styrofoam.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
Yeah, they saw all the success
of paper straws and thought,
"Let's try it
with boiling hot soup."
[ Laughter ]
I had a great night
last night.
I went out to, uh --
I went to Carbone.
-Ooh.
-Yeah.
So I went with a my friend
Mike Birbiglia,
a very funny comedian, and we're
talking about stand-up,
and he's like -- he's like,
"Yeah, you should
do stand-up again."
And I go, yeah, I know,
because I did start my career
in stand-up, and I go,
I just haven't been on stage
in probably 10 years.
And, you know,
Chris Rock tells me
I should do stand-up again.
And I go, "Yeah, I know.
I just got to get an act
and blah, blah, blah."
He goes, "You should go
to the Comedy Cellar
and just go up," and I go,
"I know, I know.
So I don't have an act."
And he's like,
"Let's just walk down there
and just -- just break
the ice of -- just the myth
of just going on stage
at the thing."
I go, "Yeah, okay."
So I went,
and it's an amazing club.
I go, "Yeah,
I totally remember it."
And you go down the stairs
and the whole thing,
and there's a great comedian,
Tina Friml, was on.
So I went and watched her set.
It was awesome.
And then I go, "All right,
I'm gonna leave."
And I went in the hallway,
and Chris Rock
is sitting on the stairs.
He's like...
"I knew you'd come back.
I knew you'd come back.
You have to come back
to stand-up.
You've got to do it, man.
I knew it.
I knew you'd come back."
I go -- and I felt
like the comedy gods
were just telling me,
like, "Yeah,
you should do stand-up again."
So I go, "Yeah."
I go, "Are you going up?"
And he's like, "Yeah,
maybe I'll go up."
So he surprised the audience.
Chris Rock gets up,
surprised the audience,
and destroys.
He's unbelievable.
And so then I went up
to give him a bottle of water,
like as a goof,
and everyone started clapping.
And then he goes, he took
the microphone, and he goes...
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Wow."
So I did stand-up
for the first time last night
in 10 years.
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was unbelievable.
I totally remembered it.
It was super fun.
It was great.
I was like --
I don't even know --
I don't know what I was
talking about.
We just made it --
He made me so comfortable
up there.
But I remember, like,
"Oh, yeah,
it's so fun to be onstage."
And when a joke works,
the crowd loves it.
I mean, like, the monologue.
[ Laughter ]
-And when it doesn't.
-And when it doesn't work,
you know, it's silence,
and, uh...
No, but I do remember that.
The room gets hot, you know,
when you tell a good joke,
and then it's like...
And then it like,
comes down to room temperature.
I loved it.
Anyways, I got the bug,
and I wanted
to thank thank Chris.
Thanks, Mike.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, Comedy Cellar.
I got to --
I'll work on an act.
-Yeah.
-I'm gonna work on an act,
and I'll be out there,
because I want to go out
around the country.
I want to say hi to everybody
and all the fans.
I love meeting people, and I
think it's gonna be fun.
I'll do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, it's Halloween.
Give me a couple of months.
I'll work on something.
-Couple months.
-All right, good.
Right now, though,
if you guys don't mind,
do you mind if I write out
some thank-you notes right now?
Is that cool with you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
James -- James, can I get some
thank you note
writing music, please?
♪♪
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, he's -- he's psyched.
-Yeah.
-Guess he's got a couple
Red Bulls before the show.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Eee!
♪♪
-Thank you, new speaker
of the House Mike Johnson,
for being the first person
to win an election
with the slogan,
"You've seen the best.
Now vote for the rest."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Come on.
Why not?
-Why not, man?
♪♪
-Thank you, Reese's Pieces,
for making me see
which one of my friends
can't pronounce Reese's.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Oh, "Reesie's."
-Reese's.
-"Reesie's" Piece --
"Reesie's Piecies."
-"Reese's Piecies."
-Reese's Pieces.
-Reesie's Piecies feces.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
walking through a spider web,
for turning me
into a black belt in karate.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Whoa!
♪♪
-Thank you, TikTok's
planned music festival,
for promising to be
a fun gathering of people
staring at their phones
for five hours.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Frankenstein,
for looking like the Hulk
after dealing with Spectrum
customer service.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Wow.
-What?
-Spectrum?
Are you gonna send that
to Frankenstein?
-I have no idea.
-So you're thanking
Frankenstein with that?
-I don't know
who I'm thanking again.
Am I thanking the Hulk?
-Thanking Frankenstein.
-Oh, wait.
I'm thanking Frankenstein.
-Yeah, Frankenstein.
-He looks like --
Because he looks like the Hulk
after dealing with
Spectrum customer --
[ Laughter ]
I don't know, man.
-You got to put it
in the mail, right?
-Hey, man, you got to do it.
-Yeah. Come on, Frank.
-Come on, man.
Come on, Frank.
-Frankie.
-Frankie boy.
-Come on, boy!
You been dealing
with Spectrum customer service!
-Whoo-ooh!
[ Laughter ]
-Are you going to send
that one?
-What's that?
[ Laughter ]
-That other one,
you're gonna send it in?
-The other one?
Uh, yeah, maybe.
I might send it in,
I might not.
I don't even know at this point.
-Just checking.
-I don't know.
Thanks for checking, though.
-Well, I want to make sure
you're okay.
-Yeah, I will.
-[ Breathes deeply ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, "It's the
Great Pumpkin, Charlie Brown,"
for the scariest moment
in any "Peanuts" special,
when you realize Sally is
just Charlie Brown in a wig.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
♪♪
-What?
[ Applause ]
-[ Imitating "Peanuts" teacher
speaking ]
-Probably Linus and Lucy.
-Yeah.
♪♪
Thank you,
fun-size candy,
for being the short kings
of the chocolate world.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
-Wow!
Big fans of short kings.
[ Laughing ]
♪♪
-Thank you, candy corn,
for being the most delicious way
to eat a candle.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my thank-you notes.